i was really pessimistic for a few years
but then
i came across bitcoin and i realized you
can shift the political landscape
through technology and so today i feel
much more optimistic because i think we
have something
which is a very powerful tool which
can't be shut down and for which you
don't need to go through the regular
political channels
you can just buy bitcoin and own it and
that's being part of this revolution
during the 2008 presidential election
vijay boyapatti
quit his job as an engineer at google to
campaign for
ron paul in new hampshire then he
discovered bitcoin and in 2018
he published an essay on medium titled
the bullish case for bitcoin which got
widespread attention and was translated
into more than 20 languages
boyapatti launched a kickstarter to
expand the essay into a book and it was
released at the star-studded 2021
bitcoin conference miami which was held
in early june
reason caught up with boya potty at
bitcoin miami to talk about inflation
how bitcoin fits with the austrian
school of economics
his libertarian origin story and what
has to happen
for bitcoin to finally become the new
global monetary standard
vijay boipatty thanks for talking to
reason thank you nick it's great to be
with you
you have a book out based on a
blockbuster article you
published first in 2017 you've updated
it but it's called the bullish case for
bitcoin
uh what's the elevator pitch of the
bullish case for bitcoin
i think bitcoin is the most important
innovation to money in a thousand years
and i think it allows the average
citizen
to keep their savings without debasement
or
confiscation very easily and very
cheaply
but there's a lot of misconceptions
surrounding bitcoin and
it's a fairly difficult thing to
understand completely you need
uh understanding economics politics
uh some law legal theory computer
science
if you if you really want to understand
how it works you need to understand all
of these things
so there's a lot of misunderstandings
out there about um
what it's about whether it's a scam uh
whether it's you know bad for society
bad for the environment
and i really wanted to address these
concerns because
i'm interested in economics i'm
interested in austrian economics and i
felt like
i had a tool chest which with which i
could
uh explore and understand bitcoin and
answer what i think is the fundamental
question
why does this thing this digital good
have any economic value it's really a
stunning
thing to happen that someone invented
money de novo
out of nothing and it is now worth a
trillion dollars it's stunning
um so i think it and we don't even know
who that person is we don't know they're
not exactly
oh we're sorry we don't we don't know
their real name right we have their
pseudonym satoshi nakamoto
uh and so it calls for an explanation
and i really wanted to
provide that explanation um in in your
writing you
you talk a lot about the history of
money uh kind of up through and you say
that you know bitcoin we are
we're witnessing a kind of rapid
evolution
of of the way money is created in a way
that you know
has really never been witnessed before
because it's it's so compressed
you talk about money going from a stage
of being a collectible to being a store
of value to being a medium of exchange
to a unit of account
um can you walk through like basically
what's happening
what what what is the typical kind of
money
supply story and then how does bitcoin
depart from that
sure so the typical uh definition that
economists use for money
is a generally accepted medium of
exchange i actually think that's very
problematic because it's defining money
as one of the roles of money money
serves different roles three major roles
it serves as a medium of exchange a
store of value
and a unit of account and so some
economists when they came across
bitcoin early on said well this isn't
money because it's not really a medium
exchange people aren't using it to buy
milk and bread at the store but william
stanley jevons who
is the father or one of the fathers of
marginalist economics
was the first to come up with this
explanation that money evolves in stages
and he was he was describing gold at the
time he's an economist from the 19th
century and he said that gold started
off as something like a collectible
it was just uh something that was
desired for its innate
properties it was shiny and it was cool
something that early man saw and thought
i want some of that
and after it's a collectible and it's
owned as a collectible by enough people
it becomes a store of value
because people recognize that there are
other people in society that value it
once enough people value something as a
store of value
in a society its purchasing power will
stabilize
to the point where it becomes usable as
a medium of exchange
so in that period when it's becoming a
store of value and people are saying i
want to have some of that because it
seems to retain its value and i can
hold it as savings into the future its
purchasing power is going to increase
over time the thing is with gold that
process
took millennia several money so you
couldn't really see that happening
uh and once
most people in society own that economic
good it will stabilize
and then it can start being used in
exchange so people start saying
well you know i can't it's not easy to
trade
my fish for your sheep because you don't
want my fish
so i'll look for something that is more
tradable more valued
um and so i'll give you gold instead of
this fish
and so then it starts taking on the
medium of exchange roll of money
and eventually when enough people are
using it in exchange
people begin to price things in terms of
it so they say
well this sheep is two ounces of gold
and this fish is half an ounce of gold
and so you get prices and that's that's
when money gets its final form which is
the unit account form
i think it's really understand uh
important to understand this evolution
of money
because people saw bitcoin and they said
well it's not money it's not doing all
the things that money does
but if you understand money as an
economic good that evolves through
stages
you recognize that bitcoin is an early
stage of the evolution it's sort of
moving from the collectible stage into
the store of value stage as
you know in the beginning people who own
bitcoin owned it just as a whimsy right
it was like oh this is a cool new
technology i just want to hold it it's
not really worth anything
more and more people saw that other
people were valuing it and they said
well it could
potentially become money and so it's
slowly transitioning to that store of
value use case now that it has
a market capitalization or at least it
got to a market capitalization of
trillion it sort of
backed off that a little bit it's being
taken much more seriously as a store of
value
by financial institutions and by
corporations and then the
end point is when we start talking about
things instead of the gold standard
we're talking about the bitcoin standard
that's right that's right what you
you've also written or you've
you've predicted you've pronounced that
um bitcoin will be the
uh reserve currency within 50 years what
what has to happen next for that to
happen well there's
a number of stages to adoption in the
beginning
uh you have people who are just
motivated by the technology and
uh they just think it's cool that they
were the cypherpunks and the computer
scientists who understood cryptography
and were working on digital money for a
decade before bitcoin came
came about and so it's a very small
coterie of people who are interested in
it
and next after that came the people who
are ideologically
uh aligned with bitcoin libertarians and
people
who are you know anti-state or who
wanted freedom for themselves and didn't
want their money to be debased
after that you started having early
investors who saw that there was
some value in this thing they were kind
of the pioneers who were willing to try
out new technologies
uh venture capitalists who were like
early to various things
said well let's put some money into
bitcoin now we're at the stage where
institutions and corporations like
microstrategy and tesla and square are
saying we want to keep some of our
corporate balance sheet in bitcoin
now eventually you're going to have
larger financial institutions like
sovereign wealth funds and eventually at
the last stage you're going to have
nation states putting bitcoin on their
balance sheet so
the federal reserve and the u.s treasury
have gold on their balance sheet and
they've had it for a long time
uh eventually i think nation states can
have bitcoin on their balance sheet
because i think most nations want uh
a form of money a global form of money
which doesn't bear the mark of any
particular nation
and those are the words of charles de
gaulle he said in
the 60s we we need to return to the gold
standard
so that no nation has an exorbitant
privilege over any other nation
and and the u.s really won itself that
privilege
when it crafted the bretton woods
agreement and uh
and and and made the dollar the the
reserve currency of the world
your interests are bringing back to gaul
is kind of interesting in this context
do you assume
that the first nation state or even
maybe sovereign wealth funds that go big
into bitcoin
is it going to be i mean it's not going
to be the u.s or china
it's going to be a kind of second-tier
major economy like so who who is likely
i think that you're absolutely correct
it's not going to be the bigger nations
and especially the us
there's this kind of irony that the u.s
is in terms of this regulation the most
open to bitcoin right now
but at the same time the us stands the
most to lose geopolitically because it
has the res
reserve current so what country i mean
at this point can you say like you know
what i think it's going to be
bora bora or it's going to be you know
who i think unfortunately it's probably
going to be some tin pot dictatorship or
kleptocracy like
north korea and it wouldn't surprise me
if north korea has
uh a team of computer programmers who
are looking to just
steal bitcoin uh because bitcoin is
digital
uh it can be stored on the internet so
unless you take care of your bitcoin and
your private keys
they can be stolen and so i i suspect
it's going to be a nation like north
korea
and it's really unfortunate uh that the
western democracies are probably gonna
dither
uh in their adoption of bitcoin i think
it's i believe it's fairly inevitable
it's the best form of money ever
invented uh so i think it's gonna be
globally adopted it's just sad that the
western nations
where you have the most freedom are
going to be the last to adopt but it's
not
money yet right so you know
let's you know what what i guess to
drill down a little bit more
what has to happen between the store of
value phase
to it becoming a medium of exchange and
we're clear i mean you're
arguing and i think most people would
agree that we're we're in that phase but
we don't know where we are on
on that adoption curve yeah that's a
great question and it really has to do
with the stability of the purchasing
power
bitcoin's purchasing power fluctuates
quite wildly right now
and that's just a function of its
adoption as
more people adopt to bitcoin the price
goes up because the supply is fixed
so you know when you have a big
flow of funds into bitcoin the price can
move a lot
and as bitcoin gets bigger the flow of
funds that comes into bitcoin has to be
bigger to move it
uh as much so in the early days when
bitcoin was fairly small the winklevoss
twins came in and put in i think 10
million dollars
and that had a pretty dramatic effect on
the price in percentage terms
if you put 10 million dollars into
bitcoin now it wouldn't budge bitcoin it
wouldn't move even a percent
but now the size of capital coming into
bitcoin is much bigger
uh so you have people who are or
corporations allocating billions of
dollars
uh eventually when you get closer to
global adoption meaning everyone has
some bitcoin
the purchasing power will stabilize and
that is when it becomes suitable as a
medium of exchange because you don't
have
the opportunity cost at the opportunity
cost is if i trade my bitcoin away now
i lose the opportunity of holding it and
seeing the appreciation into the future
and the classic story of this is the guy
who bought
two pizzas for 10 000 bitcoin which are
now worth you know
350 million dollars and and most people
in the bitcoin space have learnt that
lesson
they recognize that this isn't something
for spending yet
eventually it will be but right now it's
for saving
it's a really good uh medium of saving
so
elsewhere you've written that um you
know this
non-sovereign store of value of bitcoin
will have
profound geopolitical consequences what
are you know what are the
top two or three that you know that
bitcoin is going to change when it comes
to geopolitics
so i think the most important one is
that
when the world's globa the global
savings of the world
are in uh a deflationary
non-inflatable currency it becomes much
harder for nation states to inflate away
the savings of their populations which
means that if a nation state wants to
fund its operations it can't rely on
inflation it must rely on
taxation their goodbye
america right perhaps america is really
funded with inflation right now not
through taxation and whether or not you
you know whatever role you think the
state should have i think there is a
huge benefit of
taxation as a as a form of funding
versus inflation
because taxation is at least honest
you're going into people's pockets and
you're saying
we need this much money because we need
to fund x y and z
uh so this is i mean it's classic
economics of
you know the government doesn't want to
charge the full price
of its services because people will want
less yes exactly right and and so what
happens is that there is political
pushback against taxation
there is a limit with taxation because
people will say no that's
too much i don't like that and
historically you know over taxing your
population will
can can lead to revolution and that sort
of thing so i think that's a very
healthy thing and
historically central banks were created
as a means of funding
warfare and so for me that's a big
sort of political issue is uh
i i really believe that uh we need to
minimize warfare in the world
and sort of pulling back that ability of
governments to fund their most
destructive uh behavior is a very
important and powerful thing so
governments could
under a bitcoin standard still wage war
but they would have to tax people for
that
and people really don't like to be taxed
for something that doesn't provide a
direct benefit to themselves
uh what's another geopolitical effect of
bitcoin
i think it helps well trade uh
definitely it sort of
lowers the friction of people being able
to trade with each other you don't have
intermediaries anymore
satoshi nakamoto's invention made
something possible which would had never
been possible in the history of the
world which is
i can send value to someone on the other
end of the world without an intermediary
and it's a profoundly important thing i
can trade with someone in bangladesh
without getting the permission of a bank
or a government and i so i think that
lowers the barrier to trade and i think
it'll be really good
for global trade the last thing i think
is it will
generally lower people's time preference
when you can keep your savings in a form
of money that can't be debased
you have more confidence uh that your
savings aren't going to disappear
and so that allows people to plan more
for the future rather
than thinking about the present which i
think will have cultural impacts as well
so one of you know one of the
interesting debates that you've
been involved in over the past decade or
so really was with
bob murphy uh libertarian austrian
school economist
who was predicting in 2010 or
thereabouts we're going to have runaway
inflation because
according to kind of certainly most
market-based
economic ideas you know like if you just
pump a massive amount of new money into
the economy
you're going to see inflation you argued
with him or you bet
that we would see deflation or not
inflation
can you walk through what the argument
you were making was because
you're talking about bitcoin as a
deflationary currency which is really
kind of fascinating
and is very different than almost any
other money supply that we've
seen but we're also in kind of a
deflationary period right now
right it was funny that you mentioned
bob murphy because bob and i
just spoke on his podcast just a week
ago about this
and we did have a bet and and and i won
that bet and it's interesting because
we both subscribed what did you get by
the way for the bet uh
i think just glorious just glory it was
a bit for glory
uh we both subscribed to the austrian
school of economics but to me
the austrian school of economics isn't a
school which necessarily says
there'll always be inflation or there'll
be deflation it's a methodology of how
you approach economics and how you
understand economics
and i felt the austrians who are looking
at
uh uh the federal reserve's
uh policies in 2008 were misapplying
uh that methodology to understanding
what the consequences would be
and you really need to understand the
banking system and how the banking
system works
and i think some of the austrians who
predicted hyperinflation in 2008 didn't
really understand the banking system
they had this view of lending
that the federal reserve puts in
reserves into the banking system and
then the banks have all this extra money
that they lend out
and that creates this multiplier effect
which then creates inflation
so they saw the federal reserve create
you know i think there's
three or four trillion dollars of new
reserves and they said well this means
hyperinflation is coming because the
banks are going to lend this
out the mistake was the banks didn't
want to lend it out
because the banks were really capital
constrained they had massive losses on
their balance sheets
so it was the equivalent of printing you
know four trillion dollars and burying
burying it underground i think the
problem in that case was
uh you need to understand the lending
mechanism and you need to understand
when banks want to lend
why they want to lend when they're
constrained in lending and all of those
things i think will miss
and you don't see that changing now or
as as time goes on
are the are they going to dig up those
dollars and start i think we're living
in actually
quite a different period to 2008 9 and
10
in that quantitative easing isn't
necessarily
inflationary when the federal reserve
creates new reserves
that doesn't mean that we're going to
have inflation only if the banks want to
lend it out
that you will you see new inflation but
what we're seeing now
what we saw in 2020 is much more akin to
ben bernanke's helicopter drop of money
where instead of supreme reserves and
giving to giving those reserves to the
banks which don't do anything with them
the federal government has created money
and put it in the hand of consumers
through these stimulus checks that is
far more inflationary because it's like
getting ben bernanke used this analogy
of having it or maybe it was milton
friedman before him and
ben bernanke uh reprised it but uh
you know flying around with a helicopter
and dropping cash on the economy
and the context in which he was bringing
up was we
we have no problem with deflation
because central bankers hate deflation
and so he said we can always solve
deflation what we'll do is we'll just
drop money on people and then
they'll have free money and they'll just
want to spend it that is basically what
has happened in 2020 so i think it was
not what
bernanke was actually doing that's why
he was dropping it on banks
he was dropping in on banks so he never
did what he talked about doing his it
was very theoretical
but the current uh administration has
done something very different which is
to drop
cash on the population and i think we're
in a much more inflationary period and
we're starting to see it in commodity
prices going up
and i you know i think there is a chance
that inflation will get to the point
where it hurts people and and uh they
will start to
recognize the savings that they have in
their bank
which are earning zero percent are
really losing value very quickly because
goods at the store are going up five or
ten percent per year one of the most
interesting things about your take on
all of this is your
you know your emphasis on bitcoin as
deflationary most people
are like i don't want to live in a world
of deflation where
the general price level goes down over
time
explain why bitcoin why bitcoin is
deflationary and why that's a good thing
that people should look forward to a
world in which they're making less money
every year
yeah so bitcoin is a deflationary
currency because its supply is fixed
it's it's a form of money with ultimate
scarcity so it's even more scarce than
gold
so gold is hard money and when i say
hard money i mean it's hard to produce
it's very hard to produce an ounce of
gold you have to dig and expend all of
this energy
but yet the supply of gold still goes up
by two percent a year we still extract
more gold bitcoin was designed in a way
that it will there will never be more
than 21 million bitcoin
so what that means is that over time as
people adopt bitcoin as price goes up
the price of goods in terms of bitcoin
goes down
so if you have one bitcoin if you owned
one bitcoin in 2010
uh you know maybe you could buy some
candy with it or something like that
if you have one bitcoin now you can buy
a very nice cut you probably buy tesla
uh and you know maybe you would have to
convert
it into cash before you bought sure sure
oh well
there was a period when elon was
accepting bitcoin he stopped
uh we can talk about that later but uh
and maybe five or ten years from now you
could buy a house
with one bitcoin so that's what a
deflationary currency is it's something
that
because it's supply is fixed or scarce
and that's being masked
because of the speculation now right
exactly because this price discovery
people are trying to figure out
is this going to be the next reserve
currency and markets
are you know a noisy messy process they
don't work in like
a straight line they go up and they go
down so
pitch people on the idea of living in a
world you know let's say
you know all the bitcoin is mined it's
been adopted as the you know as a global
standard
um why is it good to live in a world
where
essentially your your salary goes down
every year
well we see small pockets of this in our
economy where
the the segments of the economy which
are so productive
they can you know overcome the inflation
that's being pumped into the economy by
the federal reserve
so technology is a good example of this
every
uh every year the price of an iphone
goes down or the quality for the same
price goes up
uh and so the argument against this kind
of deflation of behavior as well
if it's deflationary people are never
going to spend their money because
they'll just hold their money
waiting for something better in the
future and we know already this is not
true
you probably have upgraded your phone in
the last
couple of years i'm guessing you don't
have a phone from 2010 in the
anticipation of a
better phone in 2030. so when people
find enough benefit uh from buying a
good with a currency that's appreciating
appreciating value they will exchange
their currency
so this is a fallacy that's used by
keynesian economists to argue that a
deflationary currency is bad
but i think if you look at the pockets
of the economy which is so productive
that you do see deflation
they are the most productive innovative
parts of our economy
and that's the kind of economy i want
across the board
i would like all of the economy to be
like that and i'd love for people to be
able to save and to think
my savings will have as much or slightly
more value in the future
than less value because one of the huge
disadvantages of having
an inflationary currency is people get
worried about keeping cash
or keeping savings in the bank and so
this leads to speculation
and when interest rates are zero you get
the speculative further where
people are day trading on robin hood and
you know buying things like gamestop
because they're worried that
if they keep cash it's going to lose
value and this is
generally a bad thing for society
because people
should not be gambling and doing things
that they're not an expert in
they should be focusing on their own
craft and bettering themselves
that's better for the division of labor
it's better for everyone in society
if doctors for example go to conferences
and and learn more about being a better
doctor
than gambling on stocks to push on this
a little bit
it's one thing if prices go down
or purchasing power goes up because
technological invasion and innovation
increases
it's another thing if there's a limit in
the money supply and people start making
less money isn't there
well this is uh you know george soldier
is someone who
who has talked about this and i've had
some debates with him on twitter and he
he believes that the money supply should
be elastic if there's more
demand for money more money should be
produced and this
is uh this is an open debate i'm not
going to say that this is a a resolved
question i think
uh selgen is wrong on this but this is
an experiment where we get to see as
people adopt it
whether these things happen or not uh i
don't
think it's a problem that people are
paid in a deflationary currency
you would live in a world where people
couldn't may not necessarily expect
raises uh in the same frequency because
people are getting raises now because
the value of their currency is going
down they need a raise just to keep up
with so they're not necessarily getting
rewarded for more productivity it's kind
of a
political decision to kind of keep i
think it wouldn't i think it wouldn't be
baked in that you would always get a
raise
uh you might get a raise because you
became more productive
but it wouldn't be like this standard
every year you should expect a three
percent raise and people expect that
because if they didn't get that
then the the salary that they would be
getting would be going down in
purchasing power
and it's purchasing power that matters
more ultimately exactly
and you know there's this argument made
by tyler cohen that i thought was really
interesting which was we we need an
inflationary currency because workers
don't really understand this idea that
uh you know that
they're getting less salary or or the
same salary over time
i don't buy that i think people are
intelligent enough to understand
hey this is different this is something
that retains its value and is
fixed in supply so you don't need to
worry that you're not getting
more of it that you're getting the same
amount i think it's just we need better
uh economic theory we need
uh people to explain this kind of stuff
and we need to
to live through it as well um you you've
mentioned the austrian school
um as as an approach to economics how do
you define that
what what is your shorthand of what's
the austrian method
i would say the austrian method is to
recognize that we
are the ultimate cause our decisions are
the ultimate
cause of price formation in the economy
and if we
recognize ourselves as the causal agent
for economic phenomena
we can do some introspection about the
motivations that we have
uh you know when we decide to buy things
or how
how we react to different policies so
for instance uh
an austrian insight is that this is
actually common to most
uh economics but an austrian would say
that uh if you raise the minimum wage
above the the rate at which a person is
profitable the owner of
the business that's employing that
person will
let go of that person and they'll be
unemployed and that's just really a
psychological
insight that an owner is going to be
motivated by
profit to run their business so their
business doesn't go out of business
and that they don't want to lose money
doing something
and so when they have an employee which
is producing
five dollars worth of value and the
minimum wage is seven dollars
they just simply cannot continue to hire
that person
and that's not something that you need
to look at in aggregates or anything
that's just a
it's what's called an a priori insight
ah
and so that's that's the difference in
methodology
austrian economics is a deductive
science
whereas uh classical economics or
keynesian economics is much more
empirical science where they sort of
pretend to be
like physics or chemistry and use the
empirical method and look at
aggregate statistics and try and come up
with economic laws by doing that
whereas the austrians start from first
principles and use deductions based on
knowledge of human desires right and
then it ties in with high x interest and
methodological individualism of reducing
the
the object of study to the to
individuals exactly right
um having said that um
mises ludwig von mises in particular was
pretty insistent that money is not a
store of value that money is a means of
exchange
um can you talk so you're even as you
are
invoking the austrian school you're kind
of being heretical right
against uh mises and his uh protege
uh murray rothbard yeah talk about that
a little bit yeah you know i find that
interesting sometimes i've come to
different conclusions to other austrians
and and sometimes so one of you has to
be wrong right that's right that's right
you're absolutely correct because it's a
deductive science axiomatically we know
somebody's wrong we need to at least
either look at our assumptions and see
whether we disagree on our assumptions
and in the case you brought up with bob
murphy and and hyperinflation versus
deflation
that's a that was a case where i i think
i disagreed with their assumptions
we had the same method but i just
disagreed they had an understanding how
the banking system worked and if you
change those assumptions and use the
same methodology you come up with
different conclusions
so i you know i've disagreed with mises
and rothbard on a few things but
i really i have a huge admiration for
mises because he pioneered the method of
austrian economics
i think it's one of the biggest mistakes
in modern economics to define
money as a medium of exchange because
that is one of the
uh functions of money and if you define
something as one of its functions it
makes it much
harder to understand that thing it's
sort of like defining
a car as the steering wheel or something
like that you
you miss the bigger picture you miss
that money is these other things
and i think you know uh at least
keynesian economists have
an incentive to define money in this way
because
keynesians are in bed with the
government and they usually push
government-friendly policies and
governments don't like money being used
as a store of value or people
thinking of it as a store of value
because they
they like to extract people's savings
through inflation
so they don't want people to keep as
soon as people start saving in dollars
and the purchasing power of the dollar
goes up it's a big emergency at the
federal reserve they say we need to
print more dollars
and we need to get the value down we
need people to be exchanging it they
don't believe in
the store value use case i think the
store value use case is
the most important uh function of money
where the world's uh savings are held is
incredibly important
because i'll give you an example of
argentina it's a country where
the medium exchange is the peso but
the store of value when possible is the
dollar
people don't want to save in pacers
because they see the value dropping
really quickly
so that's an example where the store of
value and the medium exchange are two
different
uh economic goods and you can see you
know going back to the
geopolitical implications no state or
central bank is going to be comfortable
if the store of value is bitcoin which
is out of their reach and out of their
control of manipulating one way or the
other
absolutely and you can hide it anywhere
absolutely if the world savings fleet of
bitcoin that really
uh reduces the power that central banks
have over monetary policy because
monetary policy
is really a way of controlling uh the
world's savings
trying to make the world savings move
and if the world's savings are in
something that can't be controlled
they can't make it move anymore so
mises rothbard at all talk
about money is the
medium through which people exchange
things but the actual store of value is
in things like commodities uh
real estate things that can grow and
develop and that that's what
our savings should be pointed towards is
there a distinction here
well i disagree with that i think if you
look historically under a gold standard
people did keep significant savings in
gold it wasn't simply a medium of
exchange
uh and just by the fact that gold held
its purchasing power over time
people held more cash if you look at the
average person today
most people don't hold much cash you
don't want to hold cash you want to have
something else that
potentially goes up in purchasing power
so
in today's world certainly you want to
hold commodities or stocks or real
estate
but under a gold standard you know
people did keep a lot of their savings
in gold and it just sort of goes all the
way back to biblical times i think it
was old testament which said keep
a third of your money in cash a third of
your money in
business and a third of your money in
your house or in real estate
so uh historically people did hold a lot
more cash
because uh the the value uh stayed
you know the same over time and didn't
drop so
mises had a theory that money emerges
from commodities
um we called it the regression theory um
bitcoin doesn't fit neatly into a lot of
the categories of
you know kind of mezizian or other
economic thinking a lot of austrian
school people
particularly who were fans of the gold
standard were very skeptical of bitcoin
um in the early days at least how does
bitcoin fit into the regression theorem
yeah that's a great question because it
was a big debate in you know the early
years of bitcoin whether bitcoin is
money whether it could be money
and it really did center around the
regression theorem the regression
theorem was
mises insight that uh the purchasing
power of money
today comes from the fact that it had
purchasing power yesterday
people have this awareness that there's
money around and
it's valuable because i remember it was
valuable yesterday
but this gets you into this kind of
circularity where you think well
where does it originally get its money
from is this an infinite redress
and mises said no it eventually ends
uh some point in the in the past when
money was a commodity such as gold and
it was valued for some
some other purpose now rothbard took
this and he went even further and
rothbar did this a few times right now
it's surprising
yeah he's a model of restraint yeah
rothmod
uh i'm a huge fan of rothbard by the way
uh but uh
i think in this case he made a mistake
he extended what mises said
which i think was a historical insight
he was trying to explain why does money
have purchasing power today
and rothbard said money must
originate as a commodity if it does not
originate as a commodity
it cannot become money i think that was
a mistake
and i think when you look at the
regression theorem it's just
trying to explain why money has
purchasing power and it goes back to
some
beginning uh and you with bitcoin you
look at the beginning and bitcoin wasn't
a commodity
but someone bought it and someone gave
it a market price
and it doesn't matter why it got a
market price whether it was used as a
commodity or was used just because
someone thought it was cool
a market price was established and
that's uh an irrefutable fact
from that point on the process of
monetization began and
and we're still in that process so i
don't think
it really violates me as mises
regression theorem at all
um but it does it it moves away from
rothbard's
exactly it moves away from rothbard's
interpretation so you know we've been
talking a lot about the austrian school
which is
increasingly influential in a
broad-based libertarian
movement and thinking do you think is
bitcoin in some profound way a
fulfillment of austrian insights or is
it just that
a lot of people are into bitcoin or also
into austrian economics
i think in the early days certainly a
lot of people who are bitcoins were
influenced by
the austrian school but it's really
interesting as well
a lot of prominent austrians never
became interested in bitcoin or
dismissed it
it was people who were i would call
almost
neo-austrians who were influenced by the
austrians but weren't necessarily
austrians
who i think had the deepest insights
into bitcoin
people like nick zabo and uh curtis
yavin is another example
people who knew about uh mises and
and hayek and rothbar but didn't
necessarily follow them dogmatically
they saw that there was value in the
method and they applied the method in a
way that was appropriate to this new
thing
uh so it's interesting because i feel
like now the bitcoin computing community
is much
larger so you have people who do nothing
about austrian economics you're coming
to bitcoin
but then some of them start you know as
they get interested they go down the
rabbit hole they learn what bitcoin's
history and why it's valuable and then
they pick up
austrian economics and and become
interested in it that way how did you
become interested in austrian economics
uh so i'm i'm from australia originally
and we don't really have a remnant
in australia this sort of libertarian
core
uh in america it's kind of connected all
the way back to the american revolution
this
sense of wanting to be free and not be
oppressed by the government
so i came to america without really any
strong political beliefs at all
and i i started working at google in
2002 and i came across all these
libertarians
and i was really struck by the arguments
they made complete sense to me
i felt like they were arguing arguing
very logically rather than emotionally
and and one of my friends gave me a vhs
tape of iron rand
being uh interviewed by phil donahue
in the 1970s i'm glad to hear you were
still using vhs in 2002.
yeah a little embarrassing but you know
watching iron rand being
interviewed by donahue in front of a
hostile audience
i've been sitting very calmly this very
small russian lady
sitting very calmly and answering
logically it really felt like being hit
by a bolt of lightning and i felt like
that was a turning
turning moment for me and i felt like
this is really important
this is a way of understanding the world
i want to i want to know more about this
and
the next vhs tape was a phil donahue
interview of milton friedman
and then i got interested in economics
and i thought wow this is great
and you know whenever i heard criticisms
of milton friedman by keynesians
i didn't feel like they were very strong
they weren't very logically argued
but i wanted to suppress press on these
ideas and challenge them see if there
were any flaws
i was looking around for criticisms of
milton friedman then i found these
austrians so
some of them were you know pretty
hostile to
milton friedman uh and i thought they
they had a methodology which is really
interesting and so i became
a fan of the austrian methodology
it's a little sad i think that there's
this fractious
nature of the libertarian community
people have gone into these little
uh cliques like objectivists and
friedmanites and
austrians i think we all share a lot of
common values
uh but you know i've been interested in
libertarianism and all these different
schools of thought since
you know the early 2000s you know so you
were at google
and uh it was you met a bunch of
libertarians there
right now you know big tech
is you know widely perceived
among libertarians as hostile to
libertarian ideas
has something changed in big tech or are
we just
kind of talking hysterically about
things certainly i think something has
changed
uh google was always a company that
leaned left
but uh something happened in the obama
administration and i don't i can't put
my finger on what it is
where it's begun to ratchet up uh
and this sort of woke culture it has
become
overwhelming and almost oppressive
almost stalinist
in in these companies where uh you have
to speak the right way
otherwise you're you're not welcome or
you're kicked out of the company
and and you know i have friends who are
still at google
who tell me how oppressive it feels and
the thing that's really i think scary is
that there's
just a massive concentration of power in
just a few companies
which all have this these same values
facebook google twitter um that they all
lean
very left now i think they've become
much more left-wing than they they're
what does that mean exactly is it
culturally
culturally left or are they trying to i
mean are they trying to make people
believe the same things they have the
same attitudes towards
society and culture or are they trying
to actually
kind of clamp down on economic freedom i
wouldn't say they're trying to clamp
down
on economic freedom uh and i wouldn't
necessarily
necessarily say they're overtly trying
to to brainwash people
it's just that that's so much power
concentrating in those
few hands which have the same
ideological belief
and they have become the dominant global
communications platform
so they get to choose which viewpoints
are allowed they get to choose what's
extreme and they get to choose what's
allowable
and they get to censor i mean it's
absolutely incredible
uh either that the president of the
united states could be banned
in nigeria from twitter yeah from from
uh you know these they have that much
power
that they can take away the the speech
of the u.s president whether or not you
believe that he was a good president
or not that is a very scary development
i think even
politicians on the left uh like
elizabeth warren are recognizing this is
this is too much power for these these
companies have
you know the the standard libertarian
response to that
is uh twitter is a private platform
facebook is a private platform
it's their sandbox they get to decide
who shits in it um
you know is that uh do you think that
there needs to be some kind of uh
you know government regulation of social
media well it's
it's a very difficult nuanced topic in
general i think the government should
stay completely out of the market
in the marketplace but these companies
have become so powerful that they have
political influence as well and i think
it's important to understand that
there isn't this clean distinction
between corporations and state
their corporations and the state get in
bed
there's this view as the state as having
agency as being a kind of
person or thing that decides thing
things i think you should think of the
state rather not
as something or a person that has agency
but as a sword
it's a weapon that people pick up and
they wield against each other
and corporations wield this sword as
well so what do you do though
i mean you know there are you mentioned
elizabeth warren she's talking about
breaking up
uh entities like facebook and google
under antitrust
other republican politicians and
democrats are
passing laws saying that they can't
moderate anybody they can't kick anybody
off or
they should enhance hate speech
penalties would where do you stand on
that
i would prefer not to use the state to
stop to solve this problem
uh ultimately though i do think if these
companies are regulating speech
and they are the major platforms where
most speeches
are consumed then they are inviting
regulation
because there is no way that you can
have
half the population in the us not having
the same values
as these companies and these companies
deciding whether or not that half of the
population is allowed to say what they
want on these platforms
but i think the the ultimate solution is
we need to decentralize
these systems bitcoin is an example of
decentralization for money we need
decentralization of communication
as well that brings you know we're at
bitcoin uh miami but bitcoin 2021
a huge 12 000 people are reportedly here
jack dorsey the ceo of twitter uh spoke
on the one hand twitter
is a bet noir of a lot of free speech
people because it seems to
randomly and arbitrarily kick people off
its platform which is less popular
i mean if you're on twitter twitter is
the entire universe
if you're 90 of americans you don't have
a twitter account or never
check it but dorsey is also probably
the most profoundly invested literally
and figuratively
tech ceo in bitcoin um and he's pushing
for all kinds of decentralized uh plays
in bitcoin as well as in communication
peer-to-peer
social media is somebody like jack
dorsey a hero or a villain or do we need
to be thinking about
people like him in radically different
ways i think a person can be both
a hero and a villain and i think he can
play both roles i think
as the ceo of uh as a ceo of a large
tech company you have multiple
constituencies
one of them is your users of course but
also your employees
and they they exert a lot of political
pressure and people outside may not know
this but
uh ceos aren't like the leader who of
companies who can do whatever they want
if you're someone like sundar pichai at
google and you have half your employees
walk out because they don't like the way
you're doing things
you're going to change what you do so
they're almost like
running in a democracy in a way so
jack needs to cater to his employees and
i think
probably in some cases these policies
coming out aren't necessarily
his uh desired outcome and he's talked
about
twitter shouldn't be a platform for
uh you know communication it should be
it should be an app built on top of a
decentralized network
and he wants that to happen so the
benefit to him of having
twitter being built on top of a
decentralized network is that
he won't have regulators coming to him
saying
you need to do this and you need to do
that he'll say well this is a
decentralized network i don't control
the speech that happens on this i've
just built
kind of a user interface on top of it
and i think he recognizes that he's in a
very very difficult position
uh having the power that he has he will
be
constantly scrutinized for the influence
he has on politics around the world
to turn back to bitcoin um you know the
early critique of bitcoin
was mostly let's just ignore it because
it's too small to matter
you know it's you know a bunch of
libertarian weirdos or cypherpunks
doing whatever then once it got bigger
you know more
critiques of it are now emerging one
which is increasingly uh
popular is the idea that it's really the
only use case for
for bitcoin is criminal activity um
how do you how do you respond to
something i think that's actually one of
the worst criticisms of bitcoin because
if
you look at the numbers just in absolute
terms and even in percentage terms
far more illicit trade and activity
happens with the us dollar
than with bitcoin bitcoin perhaps in the
early days
because of the people who are uh
attracted to bitcoin had this very
uh strong anarcho-capitalist ideology
they wanted
anyone to be able to trade drugs and so
they were like this is a perfect
currency for that
i think over time in an early kind of
demonstration project the bitcoin was
silk road
exactly exactly right and so people it
got this brand it was associated with
silk road and
the drug trade i actually think that was
a big sort of
uh branding problem for bitcoin because
bitcoin is not really good for
that kind of trade the the bitcoin
blockchain is open and transparent
and exists in perpetuity so if you're
transacting drugs online with bitcoin
you know five or ten years down the road
someone might be able to trace those
bitcoins to something that you buy
at another store like amazon and then
get your identity and say
well we know this was used for drugs so
bitcoin's actually not a good currency
to use for drug trafficking and i i
would say the
overwhelming usage of bitcoin is as a
savings vehicle
uh rather than for illicit trade what
about the in
environmental attacks on bitcoin the
idea that bitcoin is
you know is already hogging all the
electricity in the world and it's you
know as
if we shift to it you know we're going
to need to start mining other planets
for electricity
well there's the premise uh which i
personally disagree with which is that
any energy consumption
is in and of itself bad i think energy
consumption is strongly correlated with
human civilization and
human flourishing so we should celebrate
the fact that we are using more energy
but if you do buy the premise and you
take the most charitable
interpretation of which i think is
always important with your intellectual
adversaries still man their arguments
let's assume that energy consumption is
bad because of the greenhouse effect
uh if you look at bitcoin's energy
consumption it
mostly comes from clean energy sources
uh and
there's a reason for this uh bitcoin
miners
uh are looking for places around the
world which produce
energy very cheaply because that's their
primary input cost
and so they gravitate towards places
where there's a mass
of uh excess energy and an example
of this is the sichuan province in china
which is one of the biggest bitcoin
mining centers on earth
and what happened there is the chinese
government uh you know the government's
never very good at allocating resources
they built
all these massive hydroelectric dams and
so they have this
gigantic amount of energy but not enough
people in the region
to use that energy and energy is not
fungible so you can't take that excess
energy and say well we can use it in
texas it doesn't work that way
that excess energy is just thrown away
it's wasted
so what bitcoin miners do is they go to
places like this and say well you've got
all this excess energy can we use it can
we get it cheap
and it's great for the power companies
they're like yes now we can actually
sell some of this excess energy
uh and so the the greenhouse effect is
actually
quite low with bitcoin because it
gravitates to places like that
like hydroelectric dams in sichuan
province or iceland where they have a
lot of geothermal
uh energy and excess energy so in a way
i think
bitcoin is good for the environment
because it incentivizes the production
of renewable energy sources
in places where creating renewable
energy may not be economic
because you may not have enough economic
infrastructure in an area
but you have an energy source you can
then monetize that
energy source and bitcoin kind of
becomes a battery
you store the value of that energy and
then you can transmit it around the
world
so i think we're going to bring online a
lot of renewable energy sources
that previously would not have been
economic and people are going to start
moving to places because
now you've got energy which is the basis
of civilization
um if those are bad critiques of bitcoin
in in your arguments for the the bullish
case for bitcoin you talk about
um real risks and they include things
like exchange shutdowns
the fungibility issue protocol issues
discuss what what do you see as the most
serious threat to
bitcoin going forward in the early years
protocol risk was the biggest risk
because satoshi nakamoto had come up
with this new system for decentralized
money
and people had been trying this for at
least a decade before
and had been unsuccessful so when he
when he posted his
email to the cryptography mailing list
it was it was met with general
skepticism people didn't believe it
could actually work
and so i think in the first few years
people really bashing on bitcoin
you know actually trying to break it and
i think it's become clear over time
people have become more and more
confident that
the protocol is actually rock solid it
can't be broken at that layer
so protocol risk has diminished over
time
i think and you've said that basically
if if bitcoin is around for 20 years
or so you know then people will accept
it as a
as as if it's always been around yeah
there's this thing called the lindy
effect where
the longer something exists the more
confident people
are that it will exist forever and so
one of the advantages i i talk about
between gold and bitcoin
uh when comparing different monetary
goods is in my book
is that gold has been around forever so
it has this long established history
but i said that's not actually a huge
advantage because bitcoin's been around
for 10 years
i think when something's around for 20
years people assume it's it's a
permanent institution in the world
the internet is a good example right
he's been around for 50 years
they'll probably be around for another
uh what about the other risks of bitcoin
though state attack i think is
by far by far the most important risk i
think
eventually nation states are going to
recognize the emergence of
bitcoin as a global store of value is
going to threaten their control over
monetary policy and i think
states will become more antagonistic
towards it and
part of the process of monetization is
just people transferring their financial
energy
from fiat to their savings from fiat
currencies like the dollar
into bitcoin nation states can attack
those on-ramps uh
so exchanges uh where people buy bitcoin
they're fairly easy to shut down and
it's really a question of
in my mind whether bitcoin gets enough
political capture
that this becomes impossible and the
example i like to give
is the company uber and uber had this
strategy of going into cities
and launching their product without
permission they just go and do it
and you know local city governments are
generally slow and and
not good at regulating new things but
the taxi lobby would get really
angry and hostile and lobby the local
city government say you need to shut
this down
but by the time they had the attention
of local city government
uber was being used by enough people in
the city had enough people employed as
drivers
that it had a constituency a very strong
vocal constituency
and that's happening with bitcoin you
have this growing very
passionate uh minority of people and
if you go down the road to the bitcoin
conference you'll see 12 000 people from
you know around the world who are very
very passionate at the same by the same
token
in places like china where you know uh
plurality if not a majority of bitcoin
miners are currently the government is
making moves to shut things down
um you know is you know how
you know how does that play out in less
authoritarian
economies i guess yeah i think
authoritarian countries
will you still have the power to shut
things down because they
they simply have that pattern and they
can decide whether to do that or not i
think
they will probably eventually realize
it's a bad idea to do that
because if you see something becoming
global money
you don't want to prevent your people
from getting you don't be lost in line
when it when it becomes the reserve
currency of the world so i think china's
actually in a great
place having most of the mining capacity
i think they will eventually uh
recognize that bitcoin is a good thing
for them geopolitically they they
would love to see a peter thiel has
talked about this they would love to see
the dollar replaced as the world
currency uh they would prefer bitcoin
to be the world world reserve currency
they make a dollar but not necessarily
the yuan
not necessarily the one they they like
to they're a mercantilist country they
like to keep the one week
uh but you know displacing the dollar
would be good for them
perhaps they may not want bitcoin to be
the world world to reserve currency
video
if everyone else is adopting it they
don't have a choice in the matter
uh so it's the the western democracy is
the one that interests me in the us in
particular because that's where i live
i am just looking at whether bitcoin
gets enough political capture
enough adoption by people who own
bitcoin that you see
politicians in congress start advocating
for bitcoin and i think we're just
starting to see this
we have our first u.s senator who is a
an open advocate for bitcoin actually
owns bitcoin
and that's a very powerful thing to have
in the u.s senate is
uh an advocate and someone who can
defend bitcoin when it's attacked by
other politicians who may not
uh know know much about it and i think
it's really great uh cynthia lomas has
talked about educating her fellow
senators
and uh they're pretty slow learners
they're they're slowly
uh they're slow learners but when their
constituents start talking about it and
when their constituents say
i don't like this thing that you're
pushing because it hurts my savings
bitcoin will eventually get to the point
where trying to shut it down in
in the u.s will be trying to like trying
to shut down 401ks
you just it's politically impossible
because uh there are enough people
bought into
uh having their retirement in for 401ks
that they would
uh they would riot on the streets if you
you behind their 401k
you uh recently tweeted at the bitcoin
conference uh ron paul was a speaker and
you
took a photo with him and tweeted out
that ron paul is a hero of yours
um why is ron paul a hero for you so
i first you know when i was going along
my libertarian journey at google i came
across ron paul
in the uh 2007 presidential
debate for the republican party they're
trying to choose a candidate
and and i remember that moment electric
moment almost like
watching iran that felt the same way uh
where ron paul tried to explain why
people in the middle east
are hostile towards the us and rudy
giuliani just sort of got in a huff
and said i can't believe you just said
that uh
they hate our freedom or you know
something like that i need i want you to
apologize
and ron you're barely fitting in his
suit
kind of cowered a little bit but he
stood his ground and
you know he got booed in that audience
that night but across the country
uh he was being cheered by people
because people believe that that's the
truth
uh people around the world love america
for its values for its freedom they just
don't want to be interfered with
i think that's a that's a universal
value and i think ron was
one of the first politicians i saw
talking about that he was one of the
first politicians i
i saw talking about sound money and the
federal reserve and he was
popularizing these ideas that i thought
was so important so
i thought he was just he is incredible
to see him talking about this stuff
that's
you know it's it both seems like a
minute ago and you know
a century ago um there was that moment
you know
with the paul ascendancy or insurgency
in the 2008
2012 elections the tea party which
brought his son to power as well as
people like justin amash and a number of
other
explicitly libertarian legislators are
you optimistic
for a kind of libertarian vision of the
world
or you know because on another level you
know ron paul
is getting older and older and it's not
clear who's replacing him are you
optimistic or pessimistic about the next
era in american politics and culture so
when ron paul came to google
in 2007 he gave a talk and i was so
excited i got up and i said
if if i was allowed i'd write you a
blank check and and i
i quit my job at google and i went to
new hampshire and i raised millions of
dollars and
brought hundreds of people to canvas for
ron paul
and that process seeing the
political process in action actually
made me really pessimistic at the time
and much more cynical uh because i
realized there were much more powerful
forces
so in new hampshire fox news decided to
exclude ron from the debate
and so that one decision had much bigger
impact than all the people i spoke to
you know all the us constitutions that i
gave at that that was cool but it didn't
have as much as an impact as fox news
saying we don't like this guy
you're out uh so i was really
pessimistic for a few
years but then i came across bitcoin
and i realized you can change the world
through technology as well
you can shift the political landscape
through technology and
and so today i feel much more optimistic
because i think we have something
which is a very powerful tool which
can't be shut down
uh and and for which you don't need to
go through the regular political
channels
you can just buy bitcoin and own it and
that's being part of this revolution
i think we're going to leave it there
thanks so much we've been talking with
vijay baipati
thanks thanks nick